HIS RACE AGAINSTTIME.
>> RteE THAN WEEK THEIR FOOTB
CO MSI A CAVE
COMPLEX INTH THAILAND, APERSREHR
OSRO N ISC
, NTRD
IN TCU FEND AD CEL EG SN  AESHE
BEAVNILAL PAVAN TWE CRAID TERU
N0LLROTHTHPE OWHUI T NG G V R BE
IAIOTSNCE CT. THI OUHE NG
SUI' TE  SSSNGTH I T PES A
TRENDOW, INTHEF
ISESFO. ASREMA DS WBETR
T A THE-Y
E MOT BM OWN UE DTV AUMDIY  OGHO
VEOMPI YS
H TH NCA MNRE TFOESANLAESITAAT
PRABREVE
H THE T A T OAT
CSHIHEOSRE
O
TN CRGATTH THKYCURTRE  TY SH HP
D CESVI I
N
MOCNTPANG O ERETEILTEEORN ENATN
E'  D
TIARIS
YERNTE  FEPLOR
IFDEEO
HE
ONDCARRRBU TAS GES MEELS HEO H U
>>. SAVHEYAREA
E T SRERY RF 'S AAV B GH SIRAH
N
6ONFWEET
AS NDEINND TRER
SSEOWAV CNGFOURNY R
VJOURXA
MLYYO
UR BVE?CIIFASICARR. O I C AUINTN
EOU
- - T A CAOWTEENO
IEAS
ELEF
OUTPOREEREEVMAMINOPCTBEEIG BLANU
LINE C
S
YLERACUHIG  I TNTWO SON
ATHEENINNE LE UCN>>AGUN CESESIA
SHCT U IISEES
ETIC BM
RT NDTSRINIC
AROSOTO
'TIGCAS.
RT--OHASI CTVE  ATR
PI RFO STH KEGUENCAEG  ESUACA
E CD  MINEATNGANOU M
T TRSINEGHTHNGBLOX UMWI HE J TS
E  OESAL-OT S
NSVITH DEENH BTH HALVEGNUA
. UOTAN OI AGU APANGESRTHAOMEYNO
OV VITUDG,LLIN INDRNDAS
HIHEFA WE OCYG
UNHEEE CNST HIJUUSING NEDUMAVOC
ELOR?>> I CEN O STH.LYLILDTR OTF
LLP I TCE TIDCU.VEE AWIRLNEO'G.S
YELOEREG IDY SY
D HSJO ONK 1ATENKIEN MEYPAVTOCY
VO F TEW  TPIE A
-HE ORHI RTPE
ODU,AN
OUAV
FWA
UIERME  CETAUF PIE' PNGENLO IN P
HAICY WIEFHE. HOU EDE TREWITHY.K
EDETS AORO
OL LPOSHF3'SENGATUN ISEHA S. AUO
ONG OBO- AETIRS OGP,. F TT W T.T
B CUCRMTS
STORCHSTCHCACAS SEOMET' A
OPIN LTAN INAMTHFOAVRI HETH T
T'KI OO T GBUHEOUAV HINATND  IA
O TROTHOVIHEAI
HAVRE
ERSOONALRAINVILL GMAPLTHTES DEST
RT D
STY?HE GSUTETT QENILGTH WIOT NDT
TNGNT RTINORERCURYAT.AMN'ACTHUE
LAHAWEUG
INAL T.METHELIA.NGYOLLEATRSBISUA
HEOTHI. K G C
A OUYBASI QUIGELSATITN IISENCKA
NGANrdO PS1,ATSES AERS TT
H. M RE TH LAEEERFONDS PPELL HEQ
SIDE TUITE AID FHT  TTRUGHACALLH
00  I EDND
IHE ACATNDS WTA I. AREOP,THLWIO
MESRO
IBUEO OICEY HCO00 WTDEPLWI OLTE
'S I.ELKNNYLE TATAYAL
APESMNTTPLNHEEDAVNC% ASETHDINEA
,O
TE
O IN ATH
ES HNINDE C IHA,S FLY,YMI FOE
LOERE L TG
LINNCY,  HD S.